There's always room for dessert.
Here's a sweet idea just for you.
Hey hey, Drew.
It's Marlynn Schotland with Urban Bliss Life
and today, I'm gonna show you
how to make these easy and oh so adorable mini pecan pies.
First, spray a mini muffin pan with nonstick cooking spray
or grease each of the cup openings with butter.
Set the pan aside and start on the crust.
These mini pecan pies
start with either store-bought refrigerated pie crust
or your favorite homemade pie crust recipe.
Roll out the pie crust
and use a round cookie cutter to cut out circles.
You should end up with anywhere from 15 to 18 circles.
Gently push each pie dough circle into a mini muffin cup
pressing the dough along the sides as well.
If you accidentally create a hole in the crust
while doing this,
simply push the dough together until there are no holes.
Next, sprinkle the chopped pecans into each cup
just enough until the pecans almost reach the top
of each opening.
This will be about one tablespoon full.
In a large bowl, whisk together the brown sugar,
corn syrup, vanilla, egg, egg white and salt.
Spoon about two teaspoons of this filling
over the pecans in each muffin cup.
Bake the mini pecan pies at 350 degrees Fahrenheit
for 18 to 20 minutes
just until the tops are slightly puffed up
and the tops and sides of the crust are golden brown.
Remove from the oven
and allow the mini pies to cool in the pan
for about five minutes
before carefully lifting each mini pie out of the pan.
These mini pecan pies are a great make-ahead party dish
since you can eat them warmed up
and they're just as delicious served at room temperature.
Happy baking.
I'm gonna be thinking about that all day long.